hi I don't know how to hold this mic
the sound off
oh this can't sound good
anyway
um
I'm not gonna put that in the video
because that would be horrible way to
start it I have to be a little quiet
because everyone is still sleeping or
some people are still sleeping my family
is an uncandy ability to sleep in the
middle of the floor as people are
walking around and talking and making
breakfast and everything like that I'm
in Korea if it wasn't clear and while
I'm in Korea I'm celebrating chuseok I
wanted to do something to celebrate a
little bit because this year I have not
been able to keep up with my Korean
studies
that's a sad fact about being busy with
the project and iron lung is just
I haven't been able to keep up with the
things that I I still consider to be
very important but sometimes it is very
easy to forget about
because up until like the very beginning
of this year I was progressing in my
understanding with Korean and I'm still
to the point where I can hear it very
well and I can pay attention to
everything that's happening in the
conversation and not get lost 90 of the
time
um but it hasn't progressed because
every day with this project I've been
busy I've been working on it well I mean
every day and that's not a bad thing it
just is sad when I get over here and I
think about that I could have progressed
over the past eight months and I could
be you know even farther
um so I wanted to do something that kind
of commemorated that
um and also reminded myself that there's
a journey that I still need to take
Beyond just the work that I'm proud of
there's also like the personal stuff
that I'm very proud of of advancing my
understanding on who I am as a person
advancing my understanding of my history
and like my family's history so cloak
now has a two sock drop if you go to
cloakbrand.com you can see that I was
supposed to bring it
I didn't
I didn't pack it
so just imagine I'm wearing it
this is why no one will ever sponsor me
I have to have my own clothing company
that I'm still very bad at promoting
because I can't I want to really
get in touch with who I am and I want to
invite you guys along for the journey I
want you guys to also see
um you know Korean culture and explore
Korean Heritage as I'm learning it you
know I'm learning it too but also I kind
of want it to be
um this gateway to bring some Korean
fashion you know into cloak and not even
that I'm a fashionable person but I kind
of want to be you know I may need to
collaborate with
um some fashion based YouTubers uh to
teach me their ways but the thing that
I've learned in my time is that you can
learn pretty much anything it is never
too late to learn something it it might
be too late for me to be really really
good at something but at least I can
have a basic understanding
um and if I'm going to have a clothing
company I probably should do that so I'm
starting that now and I'm gonna actually
document the journey as I go along
that's kind of what next year is going
to be is really me focusing on you know
my Korean side of things I want to CL I
want to collaborate with Korean
YouTubers I want to collaborate with
like obviously fashion YouTubers and
stuff like that I wanna I just want to
get out more I've been very insular on
the projects that I work on and I'm very
proud of it and I'm very happy to do it
but also
you know I sometimes feel like I live in
a bubble where I'm so busy working on my
own thing that I don't even share the
things that I'm working on with you guys
let alone other YouTubers and other you
know peers or on Tick Tock or anywhere
and so I wanna
you know
I wanna
I don't know
seems fun so I'm gonna do it that's kind
of been my only motivation to doing
anything so it seems fun I'm gonna do it
anyway you can check it out
clickbrand.com but I have another favor
to ask my phone go so I have cousins
right I have many cousins um so my my
cousin yazin
um she is a hair stylist and she's
actually toured around the world with um
a few K-pop bands I believe big bang and
I don't know my K-pop bands um but many
others she's told me about it before but
I forget what they are now you get work
based on your social media presence
apparently and this is not relatively
new you guys probably know this already
but uh for my cousin she's very talented
and she's worked with a great many
people and she's toured around the world
with them but lately because her
Instagram is not what other peoples are
she's not able to get as much work so
that's my cousin this is my cousin's
Instagram she's very good I think she
offered to do my hair and she wanted to
do a video and I will do that eventually
with her I will do a video where she
Styles my hair
um I have to keep this hair just for the
movie and maintain this that's why I
look so scruffy that's why the beard is
like this I swear to God I look more
kept together
on my usual days but nowadays I look
like this and I can't wait to be done
with that
um but for now if you can give her a
follow because it's it's not even just
about like the follower count when she
is on tour with these bands
when she's on tour with these bands and
they tag her in pictures because she
interacts with them every day she does
her hair stylist stuff like that you
know people get very jealous of that
they see who is this why is she able to
interact with the the K-pop groups that
I like and so she gets a lot of hate and
it's totally undeserved
um give her a follow and support her
work she's family and she does good work
and it'll help her in the future I'm
gonna do an Instagram live with my mom
um she wants to start a YouTube channel
um so I'm gonna help her with that she's
been in videos that I've made but I
don't think she understands the actual
full process of doing YouTube stuff so
I'm gonna try a teacher now we're going
to talk about that tomorrow I believe
today we're going to do some uh
go eating we're gonna eat we're gonna
eat a lot that's what chuseok really is
for my family anyway we eat we eat
Non-Stop and we barbecue outside and we
eat if there's one thing that Koreans
love to do
it's eating
so I'm gonna go eat with my family thank
you guys uh links are in the description
for everything if you don't remember go
back and look at it
thank you bye